[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم في صالون جديد من برنامجكم
الندوه ونقاشها اليوم او موضوع اليوم هل
يوجد حضاره مغلقه على نفسها لا تقبل
التاثير ولا التاثر حجر اصم لا يوجد فيه
مسامات ولا مسارب لايمن
لممرات المياه ولقطرات المياه او لنسمات
الهواء ام ان الحضاره نسق مفتوح
تؤثر وتتاثر تعطي وتاخذ هذا هو نقاشنا
اليوم وبشكل محدد ومباشر حضاره الجزيره
العربيه او الجزيره العربيه وحضارات واحنا
نقول الحضارات احنا فنحن نعني همم انماطم
متعدده والوانا متعدده من هذه الحضارات
وجوانب متعدده جانبها الثقافي جانبها
الاقتصادي جانبها السياسي وجانبها الفكري
ايضا والفني والمبلغ ومفردات كثيره داخل
في هذا الامر مثل الطعام مثل الازياء مثل
الموسيقى الى اخره
شريك الندوه اليوم لعله يكون من خيره من
يتحدث في هذا الامر بالذات في حضارات
الجزيره العربيه الاستاذ الدكتور سليمان
الذياب عالم الاثار السعودي واستاذ اللغات
والكتابات العربيه القديمه والمستشار
العلمي ايضا في مركز الملك فيصل للدراسات
مساك الله بالخير يا دكتور سليمان
نشاط علمي في في حائل السعوديه وكان سبب
القائك للمحاضره في حائل كشف جديد همم تم
تم ازاحه النقاب عنه في حائل همم وفي جبال
حائل هلا حدثتنا كم مدخل للحديث عن هذا
الامر
لا شك الحقيقه حائل تقع لثقب المعروفه
لجميع في شمال المملكه في وسط شمال
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
تبين لهيئه التراث نهايه الاثار لهيه
الاثار وجود الحقيقه نقشين
يعودان الى الملك
البابلي وهو اخر ملوك بابل نابوليت وهذا
يعتبر بحد ذات الحقيقه اكتشاف علمي متميز
الان تجري الحقيقه
الابحاث والدراسات في الهيئه من اجل كشف
همم غموض هذا الناس وما هو وما يتضمن هذا
النص من من معلومات عن هذا الملك الذي قدم
الى شمال شبه جزيره العربيه
وتمكن من السيطره على عدد من مدنها
المعروفه انا ذاك اللي هي تيماء وديدان
وخيبر وفدك اللي هي اليوم تسمى الحائط
وكذلك اخر هذه المدن مدينه الرسول عليه
الصلاه والسلام
نعم نعم
قبل الاسلام بكم تقريبا
اكثر من الف سنه الف سنه وشويه الف سنه
و100 تقريبا وفي القرن الخامس
قبل الميلاد هذا نابونيت كان اخر ملوك
مملكه بابل هي الفتره الثانيه الباب
الثاني يسمونه او الكلدانيه
هو ابن احد يعني العوائل العوائل المعروفه
والنبيله في مدينه بابل همم قلده الكهنه
مجمع الكهنه في ذلك في تلك الفتره زمام
الامور في بابل همم وفي تصوير طبعا ان
قدومه لهذه المنطقه كان بهدف همم تاسيس
وانشاء مملكه جديده له لانه تبين له
لفريقه الحاكم انا ذاك في بابل ان الظروف
انا ذاك طبعا في ذلك الوقت لم تكن مواتيه
استمرار الامبراطوريه البابليه العظيمه
التي كان احد ملوكها اعظم ملوك تلك الفتره
ان ابوخذ نصر التي تعود اليه الحدائق
المعلقه احدى عجائب الدنيا السبع همم
واكبر واضخم سور بني في بابل في العالم
انا ذاك كان بني حول مملكه بابل او مدينه
بابل تحديدا العاصمه في عهد هذا الملك
مختصر
هذا السؤال كون هذا الملك البابلي الذي
يتبوا على راس مملكه شديده الحضاره
والبنيان الحدائق المعلقه والشور العظيم
الذي اشارت له حتى الحضاره المعنويه
الافكار
واللاهوت الذي كان عندهم والكهنه الى اخره
ياتي الى شمال الجزيره العربيه فيه مدن
يعني فيه حضاره في استيطان بشري وفي تحضر
ما يعني ان التحضر في الجزيره العربيه ليس
بحديث النشاه بل كان في همم بؤر حضاريه في
الجزيره العربيه اليس كذلك
الجزيره العربيه وشبه الجزيره العربيه بما
فيها المملكه العربيه السعوديه طبعا كما
تعلم اخي العزيز مساحه اكثر من 300
3000000 كم مربع المملكه العربيه السعوديه
تحتل اليوم ايضا اكثر من 2 مليون مربعه
فهي غنيه كثيرا
بالمراكز الحضاريه المتميزه والمدن
والدويلات المدن المعروفه والممالك التي
عاشت في همم في اطرافها وفي وسطها وفي
انحاء متفرقه من الجزيره العربيه الجزيره
العربيه الحقيقه عمقه تاريخي يعود الى الى
ملايين السنين ليست فقط الى الى فتره بنيد
او قبيله
لدينا ادله تعود الى العصور الحجريه
القديمه كالعه العصر الحجري القديم والعصر
الحجري الوسيط والعصر الحجري الحديث لدينا
الاف المواقع التي تعود الى هذه الفتره
التاريخيه تحديدا في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه وفي بقيه مناطق شبه الجزيره
العربيه هي لا طبعا الاكثر موجود الحقيقه
في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه اليوم وهذه همم
وهذه المواقع الاثريه همم الحقيقه صوره
صادقه لمكانه او لما قدمه انسان تلك
الفتره همم نيسان في الجزء العربيه همم
للجدار الحضاري
برجع الدكتور على موضوع مداريك عن اعمال
الكشف والتنقيب الاثري في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه منذ ان بدات الى اليوم ندع هذا
الموضوع لكن ساسال سؤال يمكن يكون مهم
لتعطير النقاش ما هي ب- بعد دراساتك همم
العديده ومضاعك لهذه السنوات في هذا الحقل
ابرز الحضارات التي نشات في الجزيره
العربيه وابرز الحضارات التي تشابكت من
خارج الجزيره العربيه مع هذه الحضارات
تشابهك التجاريا اجتماعيا ثقافيه لن نقول
ابرز الحضارات في الجزيره العربيه ولو
بشكل سريع الحقيقه الجزيره العربيه غنيه
في الواقع بالحضارات التي تعود الى كافه
العصور العصور الحجريه او العصور
التاريخيه واا اذا عندنا العصور الحجريه
ايضا لدينا اخر احصائيات اللي موجوده في
ااا عند همم هيئه الاثار همم على الاقل
تزيد على 10,000 موقع يعود العصور الحجريه
كل هذه الحقيقه تدل على الانسان في تلك
الفتره مارس حياته الطبيعيه في التقنيات
المعروفه انذاك في العصر الحجري وانت تعلم
العصر الحجري الحقيقه فتره طويله جدا يعني
استمرت تقريبا من ملايين السنين الى
120,000 سنه قبل الميلاد كل هذه كانوا
يسمونها العصر الحجري هو مقسم للعده اقسام
رئيسيه الحجر الحجر العصر الحجري القديم
ثم المتوسط ثم المتاخر وكل هذه الاقسام
همم تبين ان الجزيره العربيه والمملكه
العربيه السعوديه من ضمنها انها الحقيقه
لها نصيب لا باس به ونصيب يعني كبير جدا
من المواقع التي تعود الى هذا عاصم مما
يعني هذه العصور كلها مما يعني ان الانسان
الحقيقه كان متواجده في الجزء العربيه
وادي دوره الحضاري من ابرز الحضارات
الحقيقه التي سميت بتعود العصور الحجريه
مثل حضاره العبيد اللي هي طبعا اخذت اسمها
من موقع حجري من موقع اثري موجود في جنوب
العراق لانه اول من نشر او او اول ما نشر
والف نسبه الي بينما بقيه المناطق في
الجزء في خصوص شرق الجزيره العربيه ايضا
هي نفس التقنيه ولذلك تعود الى هذه الفتره
العبيد وعندنا مثلا على سبيل المثال همم
حضاره ما اساميه حضاره او نسميه تجاوزا
الحقيقه الحضاره اللي هو حضاره المقر اللي
في وادي جنب وادي الدواسر وعند همم
يعني اظن شرق البيشه في منطقه بيشه بين
منطقه بين وادي الدواسر وبين بيشه هذا يضم
الحقيقه همم
دليلا قاطعا على الانسان ذلك العصر
الحقيقه تعامل مع الخيل في ال- في القرن
همم في الالف السابع قبل الميلاد في خلاف
كان التاسع او السابع بس لانه الباحثين
استقروا على على هذه
الزمن اجمل اقرب الى حد ما والقرب نسبه
طبعا يعني مثلا نقول 5000 قبل الميلاد
3,000 قبل الميلاد
في بعدين جاءت العصور الحجريه العصور
التاريخيه فلنجف العصور التاريخيه تعددت
الممالك وتعددت المراكز المراكز الحضاريه
في الجزيره العربيه اذا اخذناها من جنوبها
نجد الممالك موجوده في جنوب الجزيره
العربيه بدءا من سبا وانتهاء بحضر اموت في
همم في شرق في شرق الجزيره العربيه مرورا
بقتبان وغيره شو اسمها الجزء العربي ايضا
تتعدد الممالك الموجوده في بدومه الجندل
في ديدان في الاحيان في همم
تيمه وفي غيرها من من المناطق الاخرى
الموجوده في المملكه في شمال الجزيره في
وسط الجزيره نجد مملكه كنده على سبيل
المثال اذا اذا تغاضين عن تصممه جديد
وغيرها ثم نج ساج في جنوب في شرق الجزيره
العربيه همم لها دورها الكبير ايضا تاج
والجرهه وكل هذه المناطق وفيلك بجسمها همم
فيلك في في الكويت على سبيل المثال وغيرها
من المناطق الموجوده في الجزيره العربيه
واهمها في الحقيقه في شرق الجزيره العربي
تعود الى يعني ما بين القرن الثاني قبل
الميلاد الثالث الثاني قبل الميلاد الى
الاول همم بعد الميلاد
موجود لدينا ان كان عنده احتكاك في
الاشوريين كان عندهم احتكاك بغيرها
نشات الحضاره لاحقا يعني
اتجهوا للمدنيه لانه الحضاره لها نوعين في
حضاره ماديه وفي حضاره لا ماديه احنا
عندنا حقيقي افترض فينا الا يعني نقلل من
الحضاره الماديه لان الحضاره اللام
الماديه عباره عن الاخلاق عن اللغه عن
الاديان عن البيانات الاساطير غيرها وهذه
موجوده في هذه القبائل لكنها لم تتجه
الحضاره
بعد الفاصل عشان نركز عليه اكثر انت اشرت
سويت مسح عام على هذا الحضارات وجنوب
وشمال والجزيره العربيه وغربها يمكن ما
تحدثنا عن الوسطنا نتحدث بعد قليل لكن هل
هذه الحضارات او المدن كما تشاء تسميها
كانت مغلقه على نفسها ام لها اتصالات مع
الخارج وهل في مثلا هذه نمط او شكل او
انواع واثار هذه الاتصالات السميحك عذرا
نذهب فقط الى فاصل وجنس ونرجع لنكتشف هل
كنا او كان اباءنا قبل الاف منين يعيشون
في بؤر معزوله ام متصلين بالعالم عالمهم
في ذلك الوقت فلا تذهبوا بعيده
مرحبا بكم من جديد موضوعنا كان وما زال
الحضارات في الجزيره العربيه هل هي نسق
مغلق على ذاته او الحضاره في الجزيره
العربيه نسق مغلق على ذاته ام نسق مفتوح
يفعل ويتفاعل ويؤثر ويتاثر وشريك ندوه
استاذ الاثار السعوديه وعالمها واستاذ
اللغات والكتابات العربيه القديمه الدكتور
سليمان ذيب ومستشار العلمي في مركز الملك
فيصل كنت تتحدث او تستعرض قبل الفاصل بعض
همم اسماء الحضارات التي وجدت في الجزيره
العربيه حتى بعضها يعود الى العزم من
الصحيحه اكثر من 150,000 واكثر من 150,000
في العصور
العصور الحجريه التي اشارت لها اصولا الى
الالف الاولى قبل الميلاد همم نجران
الشمال شرق الجزيره العربيه وبداتنا
بحضاره العبيد التي كانت اقدم من حضارات
في شرق الجزيره العربيه
همم ثم اظن توقفت عندكم تريد تتحدث عن
الانبات ثم سنكمل يعني بس نكمل الحديث عن
الانباط وايضا وصلت الجزيره العربيه ان
كان اللي هي اليمامه ومن اليمامه
ردا على سؤالك عن قضيه هل كانت الجزيره
العربيه منزله او كان شعب ومجتمع الجزيره
العربيه مجتمعات هذه الذي يكون فيه سيفساء
جميله جدا سواء بتضاريسه او بعاداته
وتقاليده مختلفه او بقبائله التي قطنت في
هذه الجزيره من شمالها الى جنوبها من
شرقها الى غربها مرورا بواسطها الحقيقه
الانعزال هو نوعين فيه انعزال ضار وفي
نزال ايجابي ولا يجب علينا عندما نقول ان
بعض المدن والمناطق في الجزء العربي كانت
شبه منعزله لا يعني هذا انعزال كان سيئا
بل كان جيدا ومتميزا انتج حضاره المتميزه
وهناك مناطق وممالك عربيه كانت من فتحه
وليس الانفتاح الذي اساء الى المجتمع ولكن
انفتاحا الى بناء دول ومجتمعات حضاريه
متميزه ادت دورها على جدار الحضاري ما
اسميها انا دائما بالجدار الحضاري بعد
تقرير
المثال حائل حائل
من ال من المجتمعات التي اعتقد شخصيه من
خلال دراسه العدد من نقوشها خصوصا ثمود
لانه كان مجتمعا منزلا ولكنه لم يكن
منعزلا انعزالا ضارا بل انعزالا ادى الى
الابداع كما نراه من كم الكبير جدا من
الرسوم الصخريه المتقنه التي تدل دلاله
القاطعه على انه الانسان في تلك الفتره
وصل الى مستوى حضاريا في الفنون لا يمكن
الحقيقه همم كغاضي عنه او القول بانه غير
متميز بل انه المناطق في على سبيل المثال
في دوامه الجندل هنالك رسومات موجوده
بالابعاد الثلاثيه فلا يمكن ان يصل
الانسان في هذه المنطقه
ويستخدم هذا الرسم وهذا الاسلوب اللي بعد
الثلاثي يكون مسبقا لديه هي على فكره هذه
من اقدم الرسومات ذات الا بعد 30 في
العالم لم نجد اقدم منها حتى اليوم على
همم في دومه الجندل نعم في الجوف منطقه
الجوف
فالانعزال ليس لما نقول انه هذا المجتمع
منزل ليس بالضروره ان يكون انعزانا سيئا
بل هو نعرف ان عزال السيء لكن لم يكن
منطبقا على الجزيره العربيه اذا اخذنا في
جنوب الجزيره العربيه نجد ايضا الممالك
كانت منزله قد اساتي نفسها على سبيل
المثال مثل قتبان مثل حضرموت في بعض
الاحيان لكن عندهم ايضا ممالك كانت منفتحه
ومجتمعا كان مفتحا كما هو عند كما هو في
شمال الجزيره العربيه مثل همم على سبيل
المثال في الجزء العربي ديدان او تيمه
يعني المجتمع تيماء والمجتمع الديداني كان
مجتمعه مجتمعين منفتحين على العالم نجد
همم لا نجد في الجزيره العربيه
كم وتنوع النقوش الموجوده في تيمه وفي وفي
ديدان في العلا اليوم العلا
في بقيه مناطق الجزيره العربيه كلها معين
في جنوب الجزيره العربي كانت ايضا كان
مجتمعا مفاتحا لذلك تجد اييي جاليات
منتشره في الجزيره العربيه سواء في الفاو
في جنوب في وسط في جنوب منطقه الرياض او
موجود في منطقه العلا او خارج شبه جزيره
العربيه ايضا لذلك هنالك الحقيقه نوعين من
الحضارات حصلت في الجزيره العربيه منها
المفتاح مثل الديدان التي تعتبر الحقيقه
من اقدم الممالك العربيه في الجزيره
العربيه مساويه في ظني الى
نفس الفتره الزمنيه لسبا في جنوب الجزيره
العربيه لانهما ذكر في نص رامي وجد في
العلا مملكه ديدان الديدانيين ملك
الديدانيين
وسبائيين فهذا يدل دلاله قاطعه على
الحقيقه على التواء العمق الزمني اولا ثم
ما نج حقيقه من تعدد في الاديان وتعدد في
المذاهب وتعدد في الافكار وتعدد في
الاعراق عاشوا في ديدان هذه يدل على انه
مجتمع منفتح الحكومه الديدانيه او الماء
العائله المالكه الديدان والمجتمع
الديداني لم يمانع ابدا في اي جاليا تاتي
الى الى ديدان لم يومان عن تمارس طقوسها
وان تستخدم كتاباتها احرفها لغتها فاستخدم
المعين لغه واستخدم ثمود لغته واستخدم همم
صفاء ايضا كتاباته هي قليله صفيه الحقيقه
لكن الحرامي استخدمه ايضا كتاباته
الاغريقي واليوناني لما جاء ايضا نستخدمته
جنبا الى جنب معا لغه ال- الديدانيه عكس
بعض ما هو موجود اليوم كالاعتقاد بانه كل
شيء خطر على المجتمع عندما يكون اجنبي او
يكون غير غير محلي ما هو صحيح ان احنا نجد
الحقيقه همم عكس هذا في الحضاره القديمه
الانفتاح على الاخر ضروري تفهم حضاره
الاخر ايضا ضروريه ثقافه ايضا ضروريه ليس
بالضروره ان نتبناها وليس بالضروره ان ان
ايضا ان ان نحاربها ولكننا ناخذ منها ما
يفيدنا ونترك ما لا يفيدنا طيب
فهذا هو الاساس الحقيقه في حضارات الجزيره
العربيه لذلك هذه الجزيره الجزيره شبه
الجزيره العربيه الحقيقه كانت يعني جسر
لنقل الحضارات من مكان الى اخر فيتنقل
الحضاره الموجوده الحضارات الموجوده
والافكار والاراء والاديان كانت موجوده
مثلا في افريقيا او في شمال شرق الادنى
القديم الى اسيا الى اسيا والعكس صحيح لا
يمكن ان حركه التجاره
كانت وما زالت منذ الازل تاتي من اسيا
وتمر بالبحر المحيط الهندي او الخليج عمان
وبحر العرب ثم تدلف الى الجزيره العربيه
اما بطريق بحريه او بطريقه هكذا كانت ثم
تذهب الى تكون مصبها الاخير الى اوروبا
هكذا كانت الحركه
طول العمر وهو بعض الناس الحقيقيه يعتقد
او يعيد التميز الحضاري ان كان تميزا
حضاريا في الجزيره العربيه الى كونها الى
كونها فقط ما مرات طرق لا انا ارى انا لا
ارى ذلك اطلاقالا المرات الطرق هذه نعم
كانت تمر بها لكنها ليست الاساس في بروز
الحضارات في الجزء العربيه
الذي
عاش عليه هذا الانسان هو الذي بنى هذه
الحضارات وهو الذي بنى هذه المراكز
الحضاريه المتميزه والمدن والممالك
المتميزه دائما الحقيقه يؤلمني عندما نقول
لان والله مدن وقوف مدن الطرق التجاريه او
مدن القوافل هذه ليست محطات تجاريه هذه
مجتمعات ادى دورها اثرت وتاثرت تقبلت
الاخر وحاربت الاخر بمثل مثل اي مجتمع اخر
استطاع ان يجعل له اساس في في التاريخ
القديم وفي الحاضر وان شاء الله في
المستقبل همم لذلك التجاره كانت عامل من
عوامل لو لم يكن الانسان
قابل لتقبل هذه التجاره ونقلها معها
وتعامل معها بشكل صحيح انما مر من عندك
انا اخذت طرق اخرى لكنهم تعاملوا مع علي
انه كان هاديا على هذا التعامل تعاملنا
كان الى درجه عاليه من الرقيه سواء كان في
جنوب الجزائر العربيه او شمالها او وسطها
يعني تكلم عن شبه الجزيره العربيه كلها
فلذلك كل هذا كل هذه الانسان العربي الذي
عاش على هذا على هذه الارض كان له دور
كبير في في ابراج في في ولاده الحضاره في
في بلاده والثقافه الموجوده عندك نعم لولا
استعداد الانسان ابن الجزيره العربيه لان
يتفاعل مع الاخر وقوته ننتج حضارته الخاصه
لما لما مرت لما اصبح مركز الاتجاه ومركزا
نعم للحضاره ايضا هو الطريف انه في
الجزيره العربيه كان يتاثر الانسان
يتاثر
بمحيطه وفي نفس الوقت يصبغ على هذا
التاثير ثقافته وحضارته
مش يستقبل فقط
لا شك انه القبائل التي هاجرت من الجزء
العربيه بدءا من الاكاديميين وانتهاء باخر
هجره في اخره الهجره في فتره الاسلاميه
وبعد في الفتره العثمانيه ايضا عندما هاجر
الكثيرين من الجزء العربيه كل هذه
الحضارات وكل هذه الاقوال والقبائل
هاجرت وال الجماعات البشريه كلها اثرت في
تلك المجتمعات لا شك في ذلك يعني عندما
تجد استخدام اللغه الساميه اللغه العربيه
القديمه في اللغه الاكاديه او في تجد
مظاهرها في السومريه انا ذاك الدلاله
قاطعه على وجود على اثر العربيه على اثر
بن جيل العربيه وغيره من وغيرها
دكتور سليمان في هذه النقطه وايضا وضع
الامور في نصابها هو هو منتج للحضاره وليس
مجرد همم محطه تمر به الحضارات لا هو ايضا
ينتج هذه الحضاره لكنه يؤثر ويتؤثر فيها
والنقطه العظيمه اللي اشارتها لو لانه
مهيئ للتعامل مع تعقيدات التجاره
والدبلوماسيه وعلاقاتها لما كانت الازاحه
الطريق يمينا او شمالا او لذهب في امكانيه
اخرى
كيف تتعامل مع التاجر انا طبعا اراها قد
تكون قاسيه شويه وليست ماريه لذلك قتابان
كانت
منعزله ولم تخرج خارج قتبان لكن القوانين
ذات لتنظم التجاره همم ستجدها كان تتشابه
مع مع قوانين اليوم لا تتغير عن قوانين
الى قولنا اليوم على كل حال همم في الحديث
لا يمل ولذلك نريد ان نعقد بعد اذنك حلقه
اخرى لتكمل هذا النقاش انا اريد ان نقترب
قليلا من الوقت المعاصر وجدل الانغلاق
والافتتاح في همم الهويه وايضا موقف همم
المملكه الحديث في رؤيتها الحديثه حوله
هذا الموضوع موضوع الحضارات اذا نستاذنكم
حديثنا لم ينتهي سنكمله في الحلقه المقبله
فظله معنا
[موسيقى]